en tiempos cuando la economía está
normal la reserva federal e intenta
controlar toda la actividad económica
que está ocurriendo concentrándose en la
tasa de fondos federales y está la tasa
de la cual tú siempre escuchas en las
noticias
esencialmente la reserva federal tiene
por objetivo ver a los bancos prestando
ese dinero se puede decir de una manera
de préstamos a un día préstamos de corto
plazo préstamos de emergencia vaya ahora
en el vídeo pasado vimos que si a la
reserva federal no le no le agrada la
tasa de interés que se está llevando a
cabo en el préstamo bueno ellos pueden
intervenir en el asunto si el banco no
hace caso pueden intervenir y la región
federal puede realizar operaciones de
mercado abierto puede comprar valores de
tesoros del mercado general y lo que
hace es incrementar la cantidad de
dinero que está en circulación lo cual
hace decrecer la demanda por dinero
incrementar la oferta y eso deberá bajar
la tasa de interés
pro federal regularmente le interesa
llevar esa tasa de interés a una cierta
zona y llevarlo un número fijo y la
tesorería que la reserva normalmente
compra son tesorerías de corto plazo
esto simplemente por implicar menos
riesgo y a veces quizás lo hagan como un
acuerdo temporal bueno dicen mira te lo
te lo compraremos ahora solo si llegamos
al acuerdo de que tú lo compraras en un
futuro a un cierto precio a ello se le
llama un reportó son operaciones en las
que se otorga un crédito con garantía en
títulos de valores el objetivo de la
operación de mercado abierto es fijar la
tasa de interés normalmente maneja en
una deuda de tesorería a corto plazo
porque es más implica menos riesgo
expone a la reserva federal a llevar
menos riesgo en la tasa de interés pero
imagina qué sucede cuando la reserva
sigue bajando esa tasa de interés para
poder medio estimular la economía la
sigue bajando la tasa de fondos
federales de 4% a 3% luego a 2 por
ciento quizás eventualmente llegando al
0% y todo el tiempo ha estado haciendo
eso imprimiendo dinero y comprando
valores de corto plazo
en este punto la curva de interés se
mire algo de esta manera pero quizás no
sea suficiente quizás la economía sigue
estancando se quizá las personas no
estén pagando sus hipotecas así que
ahora la reserva federal no puede hacer
su tradicional operación de mercado
abierto y ya no se enfocará más en la
tasa de fondos federales porque no puede
bajar más ha llegado a cero los
préstamos a corto plazo entre los bancos
ya llegó a cero pero si la reserva
quiere inyectar por así decirlo más
dinero debe ahora comprar nuevos tipos
de garantía por ejemplo en lugar de
valores de tesorería a corto plazo
pueden ser quizás a largo plazo y quizás
aquí sea hacia un año dos años cinco
años diez años ahora que hay dos cosas
en primer lugar para inyectar dinero en
el sistema imprimir dinero y exhibirlo
para que la gente invierta en el sistema
bancario y opere pero quizás sean para
implícitamente controlar la curva de
interés que salga más o menos algo así
que se aleje más para que la deuda baje
y la curva de interés sea algo de esta
manera porque si está comprando
vencimientos largos en tesorerías eso
hará que la curva de interés baje o
quizás se empiecen a comprar
que no son de solerías quizás compren en
valores respaldados por hipotecas para
que eligiera por así decirlo al mercado
de hipotecas para que lo hablan de un
poco y este tipo de intervención no
tradicional donde la reserva federal ya
no está fijando su objetivo en el
porcentaje de la tasa de interés porque
y bueno ya está en 0% la reserva federal
ya no estaba comprando deudas a corto
plazo sino está intentando comprar
deudas a largo plazo que están bajando
la curva y manejando cosas que no son
tesorería quizás están comprando deudas
corporativas o quizás compran valores
respaldados por hipotecas a eso se le
llama flexibilización cuantitativa y hay
dos cosas que las en diferentes de otras
operaciones de mercado abierto
tradicionales de la reserva federal ya
no les importa la tasa de fondos
federales porque ya está en 0% y lo otro
es que quizás están comprando cosas más
abajo de la curva de interés intentando
controlar la curva de interés y quizás
están comprando valores menos
tradicionales con el fin de quizás hacer
esos mercados un poco más operacionales
por así decirlo bueno nos vemos